when Tom was doing the biggest numbers
yeah what was his day plan people want
the detail mate do you want the real
answer or do you want me to give you a
yeah let's keep it real mate to the real
answer is I had no day plan okay I I was
drunk you know I talked about this I had
an alcohol problem and when I was at my
peak of recruitment I was drunk I was a
functioning alcoholic you know I was
traveling the country I was up in
Bradford Norwich I was in Reading I was
supporting some big big software
projects I was out with the program
managers the project managers the pmo
managers I was I was going for lunches
and that was a period in my life when I
didn't have that structure because I was
living the dream I was building 500
Grand a year I had a team of resources
working for me which is still a massive
skill and people don't do those things
as much anymore and that was largely
what enabled me to do the big numbers